Stars, galaxy, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man over wings.
T is such a wonder thing, behind us all come see, come take your place, we're leaving soon for...
There's no seven seriously so far, and you are in the second category, Captain.
If you continue to ignore my instructions, and they are very precise, absolute rest,
then, Captain, I cannot be responsible for the consequences. I mean that.
Now I'll return to my patients.
Please send a detail of men to bury the three who died.
Three dead, four re-wounded.
Not as bad as I feared, considering the force with which we hit the ground.
The truth is, when the crash came, I thought we were goners.
Go on, Norrell. What are the chances of fixing the ship?
Well, sir, the motor area was heavily damaged when we hit.
It's such a mess now, there's no way of telling to what degree it was destroyed.
It'll take three or four days to assess the damage.
But she's a well-constructed craft, and the engines are good, solid construction.
It could then take three or four weeks.
Captain, even if the engines function, the spaceship itself is beyond repair.
True, Lieutenant, but if we can get the engines to fire, we'll manage the rest.
You'll see, there's always a way.
On that optimistic note, I'd like to know what our chief navigator thinks.
Oh, I don't know, Captain.
Where we are, even this constellation, it isn't charted.
No indication at all.
It's curious all the same.
A large green planet with a red sun, no other body.
We need one more to do triangular plotting.
There's no way otherwise.
What about the radio?
Do you think that Omega or even one of our ships would receive one of our distress signals?
It's difficult to say.
Disturbances caused by the explosion.
There's never been a situation like this one, at least not in my time.
Wouldn't you say repairing the radio ought to be our number one priority, Captain?
Thank you for your advice, Lieutenant.
That idea had occurred to us.
Our radio is in little pieces, I know.
Try to rig up something that will get a signal off on shortwave.
In the meantime, we'll have to see to our survival.
Survival here? But you realize, Captain, it's out of the question. We can't survive here for long.
Why can't we? All things considered, we were quite lucky.
This is a relatively old planet. There isn't one active volcano here.
We have to look around and consider all the advantages it has to offer.
There must be animal life here.
You say it, but no observation has detected any life.
Aha! Remember, young men, the fact of finding no recognizable technology proves nothing as to the presence of life form.
It could well show itself in an altogether different way.
Quite so, quite so. The sooner we know, the better. Off you go.
Carry out full reconnaissance. You're a geologist, I believe.
Do I go with him, Captain? There are certain investigations I'd like to carry out.
These young people are fully qualified. No, I need you here.
The truth is, there's so much to do, I don't know where to begin.
There are a thousand and one details to see to.
Why not let me organize things? I do it very well.
All right, little fellow, let's see what you can do.
Given the presence of large forests and the particular quantity of oxygen and nitrogen,
we will certainly find some sort of food.
Needless to say, priority number one is survival, and that means food, and that is alimentary, so to speak, a necessity for you, not for me.
Second priority, setting up teams to reassemble and repair the damaged structure and equipment.
And third, since we cannot possibly live in the spaceship in its present condition, you must cut trees for wood, build houses, and build a hospital.
About an hour from here, we found clay. We can make building bricks.
We can float the clay here on large rafts if we want to.
We're leaving now, Captain. Take care of yourself, sir.
Don't let the captain overtire himself, Mr. Sanders.
And are you taking this brilliant fellow along with you?
The three of us are a team, sir.
We sort of count on each other.
Don't worry. We'll return as soon as we can.
Hurry! Evacuate the ship!
Captain, the Ursus is in danger of sliding away. Brace it up.
Brace it up? What an idea.
Everyone who can work is already detailed.
They're all out working. Who could do it and with what?
Anyway, the ship is in no danger as is. What nonsense!
Don't you worry. We'll watch it and do whatever's necessary.
shade over there. I would say that they are mammals of the plasticine era. They are mammals,
and all mammals are edible, no matter in what environment they have found, because their
biochemical bases are the same. We shouldn't go any farther. We'll set up camp here, and that's
enough for one day. Let's set up camp on that mound over there. It'll make a good observation
point. It looks to me as if we're edge of a galaxy. Hey, Lieutenant! Long way from any true
civilization, but it's only a guess, really. I can't be sure. I would suggest that you go to sleep.
you're tired. I will stay on guard and I will make a few observations of my own in any case.
I am the most competent here as you would expect. Well, anyway, I'll watch the sky and I'll figure
out where we are. Good night. That's curious. Psyche, look, I think this proves there's a
civilization here. May I announce that I have discovered a resinous secretion on certain trees
which is subjected to heat can prove to be very useful. Quite interesting, really. I'm think sure
he's in the spider family. Could he be the one, I mean, the creature who carved the stone I found?
I don't think so. It doesn't look as if he could hold on to that stone to work it.
I'll tell you one thing. This is the strangest planet we've seen so far.
You know, you humans always think it's strange. Any creature that doesn't resemble you.
True, we are abroad, as they say. Naturally, creatures are unlike you.
But consider, it wasn't so very long ago, a few hundred million years on Earth,
the creatures didn't look much like you either.
I recall to you the Splendous Clutosaurus and the Demetrodon and the Cignathosaurus.
Very nice in its way. And there is also the Moa and the Tyrannosaurus.
Have a look over there.
No, Pierrot, no.
What's wrong?
It's got another signal. It was a warning. We're in danger.
We're in danger? What is it?
Bad creatures are all around.
That's fascinating.
We have to fire in self-defense. Here it goes.
Let's calm them down a little.
No, Pierrot. They will return.
We're in our weapons in self-defense. Post guards at the camp. They're ferocious. They're here.
He says they just won their first victory over their enemies, the ferocious Xavus.
To thank us, they will always come to our assistance anyway.
I've just thanked them and promised that if ever they need our assistance...
No one in the spaceship at the time.
Now, barring some unlikely rescue mission, we must resign ourselves to spending the rest of our lives.
Well, young geologist, what can you tell us of our new home?
Well, the soil can be cultivated over large areas, and there are animals, mammals, which are always edible.
There is good reason to believe they can be domesticated and even milked.
We located regions of clay which we can bake.
Therefore, we can make pottery and building bricks.
It now remains to find a cement and sand of some sort to start construction.
As for glass, I think we have a solution, but it will require prospecting and taking samples and analyzing.
Lieutenant, will you describe the environment? What did you find?
Well, first, I'd like to mention two animal species.
They walk erect.
Zabu's terrifying carnivorous creatures. At all costs, we must approach them with caution.
And the little patakis, a species of primitive humanoid, essentially friendly.
The difficulty at present is discovering a way of communicating with them.
We're quite sure they use ESP.
Following your instructions, we posted guards around the entire perimeter of the camp.
And we're constructing a barrier.
Yes, and it's taking men away from much more important work elsewhere.
And all that because of some crazy story of monsters and telepathic bugs that may not exist.
And these, do they exist?
I sincerely hope that one day you are face-to-face with those creatures, then you'll see.
Gentlemen, that will do.
We need everyone if we're going to survive.
And I'm still in command here, you understand, Sanders?
How would our brilliant little friend describe the situation?
Well, the brilliant little friend would say, according to his rapid calculations,
We are located on another arm of this galaxy, more precisely on a satellite of a red sun,
which itself was captured into the gravitational field of a blue giant star.
Now the scientific explanation is once formed, a satellite of the red sun,
that sun was drawn toward the larger star.
I don't think we need all the details.
Hey, well, if you're in a hurry.
Nevertheless, I believe I am not wrong in thinking that you may be interested in the fact
that this planet will not maintain life support conditions much longer.
Huh? Uh-huh.
That's right, in a little over 800,000 years.
The winters will be harsh.
In addition to building shelters, you will be required to make clothing to keep you warm.
You will, no doubt, dry natural fibers found on the planet, exposing them to the heat of the sun.
Then you will surely make spinning wheels and weave cloth.
Water wheels will be very useful to supply power to turn the machinery.
Certain resins have properties resembling rubber.
They can be used to impregnate skins and produce leather to make shoes.
Later, you should wish perhaps to create light using windmills constructing dams.
Later, you can increase the comfort of your houses with furniture.
And finally, for tools, you might construct solar ovens to cast metal into any form according to your needs.
I assure you, there is metal here.
It is in that direction.
It is difficult to say with precision how much...
Yes, yes, thank you.
No question about it.
Your contribution is important.
With respect, Captain, I have not completed my report.
I would suggest repairing our radio to attract any possible passing spaceship.
We patched it up, but it won't send a signal beyond our ionosphere.
How annoying all of you can be.
Please, don't interrupt. Clearly, you must position the radio transmitter outside this planet's ionosphere.
You don't say?
Of course, of course. We all agree you're right, my lad. A satellite out in orbit, yes, but how do we do it?
Nothing to it. You just employ one of the shuttle vehicles in the ship to put the radio into its orbit child's plate.
Metro says the metal deposits are this way.
Well, too bad he's not here now to show us.
He'll be much more useful at camp. Metro really knows how to take charge.
I'm worried about the captain.
Yes. He's still very sick. And I tell you, that's Sanders. I don't know. I don't trust him.
The shuttle vehicle! They got it off the ground!
I'll take the first watch.
No, you sleep. My vibrations tell me we're not in danger.
Let's go have a look over there, behind that plateau.
We should rest in the shade.
Mm-mm, no.
Metro to be wrong. No metal posits here.
Well, maybe it's further on. Probably over there, on the other side of those craters.
I hate to have one of those ape characters reappear for another round. They could be anywhere.
I don't think we'll run into them. We're not in danger.
If we were, they would tell me.
They would tell you. Oh, great.
Keys are coming.
He says we should be careful.
He says right ahead are some terrible creatures.
The horrible green apes?
No, a species that resembles us.
They resemble us? How do they know things like that?
He just received a message.
Oh, sure, he got a telegram.
Oh, by telepathy.
He's in constant contact with all his people by telepathy.
He's surprised that we need radio transmitters to communicate.
He says only way to know what's in someone's mind.
he's right sure he's right meanwhile can he take us to our cousins yes he'll take us let's go ship
from cassiopeia that's the metal that metro said we would find oh look one of their expedition is
going toward our camp we have to warn them that they're in danger the radio no don't do that
they'll receive the signal the only way is for us to get back to the camp first come on says use
the stream it turns into rapids but how can we there isn't time for us to construct a raft
You've forgotten they're our friends.
Six. There are 26 of them and they look well-armed.
Hurry.
This is exactly what we needed.
He says you and I should go on.
He and his people will hold back the Zabus.
He says he has a plan.
We should go on to the camp.
To see the cap.
That what you wanted?
All the same, Saunders. I just told you there's no time to lose.
In less than two hours they'll be here.
We have to put up defense barricades, station them in, issue weapons.
Come on, Saunders.
Are you refusing to carry out your duty?
Look, Lieutenant, I don't see why we can't discuss the situation with them.
But you must understand, the only way that you can discuss things with the Cassiopeans is from a position of superior force. That's all they understand.
We are in no position to fight them. We have almost no weapons, and our survivors hardly inspire confidence.
What idea of what will happen to them if they fall into the hands of the Cassiopeans?
We have decided we would rather go on living under the Cassiopeans than die glorious heroes. Isn't that right, you guys?
Lieutenant, I order you to organize immediate resistance.
You aren't ordering anyone here.
See, I'm the one in command here, not you, Lieutenant.
And you are refusing to follow orders.
Arrest this officer. Lock him up.
You guys, go on, shoot him!
Managed to find all that metal that I detected.
It was quite a quantity, I suppose. A game or something?
Down the shuttle vehicle.
Repeat, transport ship is now circling the planet and sending shuttle vehicles.